The other thing that's interesting about
that is that what's happened is that
the people who have these
radical viewpoints have been
given a permanent sign it
cure right there,
there their state and tuition sponsored
activists who can spend every single
moment of their time on what I would
consider their fifth call them agenda.
So we're basically funding a cohort of
people who stated purpose is to demolish
the patriarchy.
Um,
you know,
one of the things Carl Jung said,
which I really liked and
haven't talked about that much,
is that the unconscious representation
of men in the female psyche,
he called the animus and the animus was
always in his estimation because of the
dream analysis he did and so forth
that that although the unconscious
representation of a woman in a man's
psyche was an individual woman,
the unconscious representation of the
male psyche in the females unconscious was
men as a group.
And there's a very large number of women
and also some men whose conception of
male yes is,
has been damaged very badly by their
failure to establish any positive
relationship with any male whatsoever
in their developmental history.
And then they project this paranoid
representation of what constitutes
hierarchical masculinity onto
the world and then fight,
bring it down.
And,
and the thing is they're being successful.
That's the problem is this is,
this is another one when I was actually,
I know that you are very popular with the,
a lot of young men,
but I was actually introduced to you by a,
a mother too.
So professor in,
uh,
in education.
So she's really,
she's not in her,
uh,
at the,
at home,
so to speak,
ideologically or a,
but,
uh,
one thing that's worrying me is,
okay,
there are certain,
certain parts of certain ideologies that
take on a religious overtones though.
And I think that feminism has
some of those characteristics.
I mean,
in Christian,
they were all born sinful and we need
to come to grips with our sinfulness.
And in the end,
only God's grace and
forgiveness can redeem us.
And,
uh,
in,
in Lutheranism at least a,
it's,
uh,
we don't,
can,
we can be forgiven by priests is only God.
Yeah.
Doctrine.
There's no escape.
And I,
I totally sympathize with it even
though I don't in a lot of ways,
but,
um,
I realized,
uh,
but within feminist and the
sin is situated within instead,
so
not only with within males,
but within nails as a collective,
which has even seen,
the thing about the Christian doctrine
that you referred to is that it makes
each individual responsible
for their own darkness.
Now the Catholics say,
look,
that's unbearable and people need
to have the slate wiped clean.
Now in that and confessional do that,
and there's an intermediary and
Yeoman considered that merciful.
And there's some real
power in that argument.
You know,
that the cynical argument is,
well,
you can just wipe the slate clean at
any time and you don't have to bear any
responsibility.
But I think that's cynical.
The Protestants put themselves in a
much tougher position because there's no
escape.
And,
but the upside of all of that is,
is that the darkness is
to be regarded as within,
not without.
And,
and as soon as you move away from that,
then while you're,
you're the good person.
And so is everyone that thinks like you.
And all the evil is
wherever you want to put it.
And,
and then as soon as the thing
that's really dangerous about that,
especially if the evil is conceptualized
as contemptible and parasitic and using
disgust related language,
for example,
instead of fear related language,
then the logical
directive is to purify it.
And boy,
that's,
that's not good.